それで今の瞬間というところは大事なんですから
そちらにちょっと話を持ってきます
人に管理できるのは今の瞬間
あなたにも私にも管理できるのは今の瞬間だけ
具体的なのは今の瞬間
他全部幻覚 実在するのは今の瞬間
他存在さえもないんです
成功も今の瞬間 失敗も今の瞬間で起こるんです
経験も今の瞬間 過去の経験も将来の経験もじゃなくて
今の瞬間ですよ 経験というのは
生きるのも死ぬのも今の瞬間です
すべて今の瞬間に起こるんです
死ぬ時はその今の瞬間でしょ
今の瞬間に不思議も秘密もありません
神秘も書いたかったんですけど
今の瞬間に不思議もないし
神秘もないし 秘密もない
今の瞬間 すごくオープンなんです
世の中でよくあるでしょ
これは神秘的だとかね
不思議だとかね もう頭が悪いに決まってるんです
ありえないんで そんなのは
あるのは今の瞬間だけ
だから過去やら将来やら
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ妄想して
混乱した思考で汚れた思考で考えるものですよ
秘密やら神秘やら 今の瞬間は単純でわかりやすく把握しやすいんです
今の瞬間というのは単純でわかりやすくて把握できるんですよ
今の瞬間以外の時間の流れというのは実在するものではなく
頭の中の観念なのです
時間やら何やら すべて頭の中のもので
脳だけの世界で実際しているのは今の瞬間だけ
人の観念は普遍的な真理ではなく
その個人の勝手な思想妄想です
観念というのは真理じゃない
だって勝手に何でも考えられますから
真理は今の瞬間 それは勝手にできません
どうにもならん 今の瞬間のことは
それは事実 ですから 今の瞬間以外時間で考えるとすべて妄想で現実ではないんです
それはもう悟りを開く人にしかもう経験的に理解できませんだけど
頭で考えたってもわかると思いますよ
で 悟った人には成功者やとお釈迦様は堂々と言うのは
この今の瞬間の真理を発見して
それをもう経験しているんだからね
これしかないんだと 他全部嘘やと思うと
どれほど苦しみが消えるんでしょうかね
今の瞬間以外あると あらゆるものはすべて幻覚で嘘だと
それ発見すればもういかに楽かというと
それは涅槃の喜びというんです
涅槃の安楽安らぎ 過去と将来のことにしか無知な人に興味はありません
人が無知かないか分かる方法はそれなんです
もう過去のことを喋ったり
将来のことを喋ったりというと
もう話になりません もう仏教的な思考を持っている我々だったら
すごく気持ち悪くなってくるんですよ
この人は早く出て行ってくれませんかと
人の話し合い コミュニケーションは時間的に見ると過去か将来かですよ
人が喋る場合でも 過去の事か将来の事か
まあニュースと同じですからね
だから時間の無駄 要するに実際しない概念
観念 妄想ですね だから悟った人にとってはニュースを見なくちゃということもないんです
大丈夫です ニュースを見なくても真理は知っている
誰にも負けません それは一人一人違うものです
いわゆる過去と将来のこと
概念 観念のこと 妄想などは真理じゃない
一人一人違いますからね
したがって 和合も同意も調和もない
観念的な世界で生きているんです
それでなんで世の中に和合も調和も平和も何もないんですかね
私は私だけの妄想の世界で生きていて
相手は相手だけの妄想の世界で生きていて
それで喋るんですよ 喋ってもこれコミュニケーションになってないんです
お互い理解しても現実に関係ないんですね
現実は今の瞬間だけ だから世の中では一向に平和っていうのは成り立たないんです
これ難しいんだから お釈迦様は一人一人で今の瞬間という真理を経験してみてくださいと
訓練しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だって長い間過去に引っかかること
将来に引っかかることばっかりやっていたんだから
長い間殻を作って殻の中に閉じ込める訓練しかないんだから
その殻を破るためにも訓練が必要になるんです
言っただけでは済まないんですよ
しかし 言っただけで悟る人もいたんですけど
お釈迦様の時代で それほど殻なく
真理って本当に何だというふうに考えている人なら
もう話を聞いただけでももうわかる場合はあります
失敗を刈り取るのは普通な当たり前の結果で
成功は稀なのです まれではなくて
まれ まぐれ ん？まぐれですね
まぐれでいいんです まぐれですからね
世の中で成功したと言ったら
これはまぐれですよ 失敗するのは当たり前で
なぜならば生きていないんです
過去の妄想か 将来の妄想か
実際しない世界で心回転させてエネルギーを浪費して年取るだけ
それでも成功したら何かをね
あれはまぐれ しかし 今の瞬間だけ頑張っている人にとっては当たり前のプロセスです
成功するのは だから 100%確実なんです
成功は仏教的にやってみると
まぐれの結果を期待しても
無駄に努力するのもなおさら無知なのです
それだから 俗世間ではこのまぐれの結果期待するんですよ
これ 期待できるものじゃないんですよね
まぐれだから それに頑張ることっていうのは無駄なんです
ということは なおさら無知ということなんです
真理も成功も幸福も今の瞬間ですから
最終的に言えるのは 真理も成功も幸福も
これは今の瞬間です  はい
それで 6番目 期待した結果は自然に現れる
真剣に 真面目に 本気で真理
事実というものは今の瞬間で
今の場所であることだと理解するならば
期待する結果は自然に現れるものです
因果法則を語られている経典では
このポイントを強調しているんです
結果は自然だよということをお釈迦様はすごく強調するんです
結果には何の努力も要りませんと
原因そろっちゃえば現れるんだよと
結果は必然的に現れるものです
原因条件は意図的に調整するもの
これよく覚えてください
結果は必然的 原因条件は意図的に調整する
だから我々は結果は忘れてしまって
今の瞬間のことだけ調整すればいいんです
随分やりやすい方法なんです
これほどやりやすい方法は世の中にないんです
まあ 6番目になったんだから
そろそろ終わりと思いますけど
はい で まだちょこっとセクションがありますけど
まあちょっと休憩いたします
はい